>>> CAN A PRESIDENT WHO IS
WILLING TO MAKE THE CHOICES
DONALD TRUMP MADE DURING THE
VIOLENCE OF JANUARY 6th EVER BE
TRUSTED WITH ANY POSITION OF
AUTHORITY IN OUR GREAT NATION
AGAIN?
THING THAT STRIKES ME IS, YOU
KNOW, WE CAN BE APAPALLED AND
WHAT WE HEARD LAST NIGHT WAS
APPALLING BUT CAN WE BE
SURPRISED?
THE HISTORY OF DONALD TRUMP IS
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT RULES, HE
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT LAWS, HE
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT INSTITUTIONS,
HE THINKS THEY'RE FOR SUCKERS,
HE SPENT HIS WHOLE LIFE FLOUTING
THEM AND EVERYTHING HE DID
DURING THOSE FIVE YEARS SORT OF
LED TO THAT MOMENT.
THIS WASN'T SORT OF KIND OF AN
UNUSUAL OCCURRENCE, AND HE DID
THESE THINGS IN WAYS LARGE AND
SMALL.
THE MAN WAS IMPEACHED BEFORE ALL
OF THIS HAPPENED FOR SHAKING
DOWN THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE,
WHO WE NOW KNOW VERY WELL.
>> BUT TO CHENEY'S FINAL POINT,
WHO IS THE AUDIENCE SHE'S
SPEAKING TO, MAYBE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND CERTAINLY FUTURE
PRIMARY REPUBLICAN PRIMARY
VOTERS, MORE IMPORTANTLY IT IS A
SHOT ACROSS THE BOW TO THE
SENATE REPUBLICANS THAT VOTED
AGAINST REMOVING HIM FROM
OFFICE, OR BARRING HIM FROM
SERVING AFTER THE SECOND
IMPEACHMENT.
>> I THINK, AND YOU CAN SPEAK TO
THIS, I DO THINK SHE'S SPEAKING
TO REPUBLICANS.
I THINK SHE'S TELLING
REPUBLICANS, THIS IS A BRIDGE
TOO FAR.
WE CAN'T GO DOWN THIS ROAD
AGAIN.
>> HERE IS YOUR OFF RAMP, WE'RE
GIVING IT TO YOU.
>> THERE IS A GROUP OF
REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED FOR HIM
TWICE.
I VOTED FOR HIM TWICE.
I'M A LOYAL REPUBLICAN VOTER WHO
GAVE HIM MONEY, KNOCKED ON
DOORS, THEY GAVE HIM THEIR BEST
EFFORT.
I THINK THE AUDIENCE IS THAT
GROUP.
YOU GAVE DONALD TRUMP YOUR BEST
EFFORT.
AFTER SEEING THIS, CAN YOU
CONCLUDE HE GAVE YOU HIS BEST
EFFORT?
AND IN 2024, IF YOU'RE MORTIFIED
AT THE THOUGHT THAT JOE BIDEN
MIGHT GET RE-ELECTED OR
DEMOCRATS MIGHT RE-ELECT SOMEONE
EVEN MORE LIBERAL OR MORE
PROGRESSIVE, DO YOU WANT TO ROLL
THE DICE ON THIS GUY AGAIN,
AFTER EVERYTHING YOU DID FOR
HIM, BASED  ON WHAT YOU'VE SEEN?
I THINK THERE IS A GROWING GROUP
OF REPUBLICANS WHO DID
EVERYTHING THEY COULD DO FOR
HIM, WHO MAY WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ELSE.
MORE TO COME ON THAT, BUT THE
POLLING EVIDENCE IS THERE AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK HE'S LOOKING
AT THE RACE EARLY NOW BECAUSE HE
HEARS THE FOOTSTEPS.
>> SHE SAID -- IT IS PRETTY
CLEAR SHE WOULD NOT VOTE FOR
HIM, SHE WAS SAYING HE CANNOT BE
THERE.
WOULD YOU?
IF HE WERE THE NOMINEE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
YOU SAY YOU'RE A LOYAL
REPUBLICAN.
>> IT WOULD BE A DIFFICULT -- I
DON'T KNOW WHO THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO NOMINATE, BUT IT WOULD
BE DIFFICULT FOR ME TO CONCLUDE
THAT IN TRUSTING HIM WITH THE
POWER OF THE PRESIDENCY AGAIN
WOULD BE WISE FOR THE COUNTRY.
NOW, THAT HAVING BEEN SAID, I
AM -- WHAT JOE BIDEN HAS DONE TO
THIS COUNTRY AND WHAT DEMOCRATS
ARE LIKELY TO DO IN THE FUTURE
IS ALSO TERRIBLE.
THAT'S THE THING.
A REMATCH OF THESE TWO PEOPLE
WOULD PUT A BUNT -- MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS OF VOTERS IN A BIZARRE
AND TERRIBLE SITUATION.
>> SHOULDN'T THE FIDELITY OF THE
CONSTITUTION BE TABLE STEAKS FOR
BEING PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
>> I THINK WHAT THAT ALSO -- I
WAS AMAZED AT TWO MOMENTS TO
YOUR POINT WHETHER THE SYSTEM
CAN HOLD IF HE'S PRESIDENT
AGAIN.
AND I THINK THE ANSWER IS NO.
I THINK ONCE WHEN YOU SEE THE
SECRET SERVICE AND WHAT HAPPENED
TO THEM, HERE IS THE SECRET
SERVICE PROTECTING THE VICE
PRESIDENT, THEIR LEADER IS THE
PRESIDENT, THEY KNOW THAT THE
VIOLENCE IS COMING FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF BAD THINGS TO
SAY ABOUT THE SECRET SERVICE
RIGHT NOW, BUT THE FEAR YOU
HEARD IN THEIR VOICES IS LIKE --
WE'RE NOT TRAINED FOR THIS.
PRESIDENT GOING AFTER A VICE
PRESIDENT, WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED
TO DO?
WE CAN'T SHOOT THESE PEOPLE.
WE CAN'T PROTECT THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
MILITARY, THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
NOT IN THE MILITARY CHAIN OF
COMMAND, AND HERE YOU HAVE THE
JOINT CHIEFS CALLING HIM AND
SAYING, THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING
NOTHING TO US, CAN YOU HELP OUT,
CAN YOU COMMAND US?
THE SYSTEMS DID NOT HOLD.
IF EVERYTHING SEEMS CRAZY, AND
THEY WILL NOT HOLD.
>> THAT IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BLACK HOLES OF THAT DAY, WHAT
TOOK THE NATIONAL GUARD SO LONG
TO GET THERE, WHAT DELAYED THAT
PROCESS.
AND KEITH KELLOGG WAS PENCE'S
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER AND HE
WAS ASKED, DID YOU EVER HEAR THE
PRESIDENT ASK FOR THE NATIONAL
GUARD.
NO.
DID YOU EVER HEAR THE PRESIDENT
ASK FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSE.
NO.
THE COMMITTEE SAID, AS SOMEONE
WHO WORKS IN THE NATIONAL
SECURITY SPACE AND THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL, IF THERE WERE
GOING TO TROOPED CALLED FOR A
RALLY, IS THAT SOMETHING YOU
WOULD HAVE BEEN MADE AWARE OF?
YES.
>> IT WOULD GO FROM THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE TO THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER OR THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE PRESIDENT,
ESPECIALLY WITH D.C. WITH ITS
FUNKY RULES.
THERE WOULD BE -- THEIR
INABILITY -- SO BASICALLY THE
MILITARY BROKE THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND AND I'M NOT SORRY ABOUT
IT.
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT'S NOT
RETURNING THE CALLS, AND SO THE
JOINT CHIEFS AND THE NATIONAL
SECURITY STAFF HAVE TO GO TO
SOMEONE AND IT ENDS UP BEING
PENCE, WHICH, YOU KNOW, PENCE,
LIKE, IT IS ABOUT TIME, RIGHT,
WE NEED TO HEAR FROM YOU, THAT'S
HOW I LEFT LAST NIGHT.
>> THIS CANNOT BECOME THE NORM.
THIS CANNOT -- THIS PROCESS
CANNOT BREAK ALL THE TIME.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT SO THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS DISCONNECTED FROM
THE MILITARY CHAIN OF COMMAND.
>> NO.
>> I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
GO AHEAD.
>> WHAT I WOULD SAY, THE
QUESTION IS CAN THIS -- WHAT
HAPPENS POST TRUMP, AND GOT TO
REMEMBER, THIS IS NOT JUST
DONALD TRUMP, RIGHT.
HE'S THE SYMPTOM, NOT THE
PROBLEM.
HE IS THE FUEL, NOT THE FIRE.
AND THERE SAN UNDERLYIE  IS AN
ABOUT MISTRUSTING INSTITUTIONS,
AND COURTS AND SO ON, HE'S THE
ACCELERANT THAT MADE IT MUCH
WORSE, BUT IF YOU DON'T ADDRESS
THAT, AND THIS IS YOUR AREA,
MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE'S,
JULIETTE, BUT THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM, YOU'RE RIGHT BACK HERE.
>> MAJORITY OF AMERICANS SAY
THEY BELIEVE THAT THE GOVERNMENT
IS CORRUPT, AND THAT IS RIGGED
AGAINST THEM.
>> AND THAT JUSTIFIED
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTION.
>> I THINK THAT SUPPORTED
TRUMP'S APPEAL.
HE WAS ESSENTIALLY TAKING A
HAMMER BLOW TO THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT MANY AMERICANS BELIEVE ARE
NOT FUNCTIONING IN OUR -- AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
>> THE DISCOURSE THAT THIS WAS
ALL DONALD TRUMP, THAT, YOU
KNOW, HE BROUGHT THIS TO THE
UNITED STATES, AND IF DONALD
TRUMP IS REMOVED AS THE SOURCE
OF IT, IT GOES AWAY.
>> THIS LOSES OXYGEN IF HE'S --
IF HE'S WEAKENED.
THEY'RE LISTENING TO HIM,
THEY'RE LISTENING TO SILENCE, I
FOCUS ON HIM BECAUSE I VIEW HIM
AS THE LEADER OF A VIOLENT
ORGANIZATION OR VIOLENT
MOVEMENT, AND GUESS HOW YOU STOP
THIS OR AT LEAST YOU MINIMIZE
IT?
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO END THE
IDEOLOGY, YOU'RE GOING TO
MINIMIZE THE STRENGTH, YOU
ISOLATE THE LEADER.
>> I DON'T THINK PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LOST ALL FAITH IN INSTITUTIONS
FULLY EXIST ON THE RIGHT.
IT IS CLEARLY ALSO EXISTING ON
THE LEFT, AND I KNOW -- I WANT
TO -- RIGHT NOW, I MEAN, FOR AS
MUCH AS DONALD TRUMP'S PEOPLE
WANT TO SMASH CONGRESS AND DO
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO ON JANUARY
6th, THERE ARE PEOPLE RIGHT NOW
WHO WOULD I'M SURE WOULD LOVE TO
DO THAT TO THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT AND URGING JOE
BIDEN TO BYPASS THE SUPREME
COURT AND BYPASS CONGRESS AND
ESSENTIALLY RULE BY EXECUTIVE --
THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE WHO LOST
FAITH IN THE OVERALL PROCESS
OF --
>> I DON'T THINK IT IS A FAIR
ARGUMENT TO SORT OF BOTH SIDES
INSURRECTION.
>> YOU THINK IT IS NOT A FAIR
ARGUMENT TO POINT OUT THAT
SOMEONE TRIED TO GO KILL BRETT
KAVANAUGH OR BURN DOWN THE
SUPREME COURT.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE THE SAME --
>> THAT WASN'T LED BY BIDEN.
COME ON.
>> I'M NOT -- I'M NOT SAYING IT
WAS LED BY BIDEN.
THEY CODDLED IT.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> THEY CODDLED IT.
>> WHATEVER YOU BELIEVE, SCOTT,
ABOUT WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING, JUST GIVE US A BREAK HERE
ON THIS ONE THAT TRUMP ACTUALLY
DIRECTED THE VIOLENCE.
YOU DON'T THINK HE DIRECTED THE
VIOLENCE?
>> YES, OF COURSE I DO.
I SAID IT MANY TIMES, BUT I'M
TELLING YOU DAVID'S POINT IS
CORRECT, THERE IS A WHOLE GROUP
OF AMERICANS WHO HAVE GIVEN UP
ON OUR PROCESS AND INSTITUTIONS
AND THEY DON'T FULLY EXIST ON
THE RIGHT, WHICH I THINK YOU
THINK THEY DO, BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE THEY DO.
>> I TALK ABOUT VIOLENCE ALL THE
TIME FOR A REASON BECAUSE I WANT
TO SEPARATE THE POLICY WE HAVE.
>> PEOPLE ARE SERIOUSLY TALKING
ABOUT CHARGING THE PRESIDENT,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WITH A CRIME OF INCITING
AN INSURRECTION OR OBSTRUCTING
ACTS OF -- YOU JUST DON'T
HAVE -- I'M NOT -- I AM NOT
SAYING THAT -- OR DISMISSING THE
CONDUCT OF PEOPLE WHO THREATENED
THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE, OF
COURSE NOT, I WAS A FEDERAL LAW
CLERK, LOOK, COME ON, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THE PRESIDENT IS
LITERALLY BEING -- MIGHT BE
INVESTIGATED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, BEING INVESTIGATED
BY THE FULTON COUNTY, GEORGIA.
>> BACK FOR ONE SECOND HERE, YOU
KNOW, AS I SAID EARLIER, IF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OPENLY AND FLAGRANTLY SAYS THESE
RULES, THESE LAWS, THESE NORMS
DON'T MATTER, THESE INSTITUTIONS
ARE CROOKED AND CORRUPT, AND
ANYTHING YOU DO THERE, FOR THAT
CROWD OUT THERE, IT WASN'T ALL
PROUD BOYS AND OATH KEEPERS,
THERE WERE REGULAR AMERICANS WHO
WERE TOLD THAT THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN AND IT WAS THEIR
PATRIOTIC DUTY TO GO DOWN AND
DISRUPT THIS PROCESS.
>> THAT WAS DISTILLED IN THE
OUTTAKES OF TRUMP'S VIDEO WHEN
HE SAID I DON'T WANT TO SAY THE
ELECTION IS OVER, I JUST WANT TO
SAY CONGRESS HAS CERTIFIED IT.
>> HE DOESN'T WANT TO SAY THE
ELECTION IS OVER TODAY, WHICH IS
WHY I WANT TO WRAP THIS UP, BY,
AGAIN, GOING BACK TO THE
QUESTION THAT LIZ CHENEY ASKED,
WHERE SHE SAID, CAN A PRESIDENT
WHO IS WILLING TO MAKE THE
CHOICE THAT DONALD TRUMP MADE
DURING THE VIOLENCE OF JANUARY
6th EVER BE TRUSTED WITH ANY
POSITION OF AUTHORITY IN OUR
GREAT NATION AGAIN?
IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE THAT WAS
THE RHETORICAL QUESTION, DAVID.
>> I THINK THIS IS THE PROJECT
SHE'S BEEN WORKING FROM THE
BEGINNING.
SHE'S TALKING TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, BUT MORE BROADLY
SHE'S TALKING TO HER OWN PARTY
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SHE KNOWS AS SOMEONE WHO DOES
BELIEVE IN THE CONSTITUTION,
ULTIMATELY THE PEOPLE WILL
DECIDE WHETHER DONALD TRUMP
SHOULD BE ENTRUSTED WITH THAT
POWER AND SHE'S MAKING A CASE TO
THEM THAT THAT CANNOT BE.
>> HE'S NOT SAYING IT AS
SUBTLY -- OR AS DIRECTLY, HE'S
MORE SUBTLE ABOUT IT.
THIS IS THE CASE THAT MIKE PENCE
IS MAKING FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU EVERYTHING
YOU WANTED ABOUT THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY WITHOUT THE ABSOLUTE
HORRIFIC JUDGMENT THAT HE HAD IN
AND AROUND JANUARY 6th.
THAT'S HIS MESSAGE.
>> I'M NOT SURE LIZ CHENEY WANTS
TO LEAVE IT TO MAKE PENCE, BUT
IT IS VERY INTERESTING.
>> MAYBE LEAVE IT TO LIZ CHENEY,
POTENTIALLY.
>> MAYBE SO.
>> I THINK WE'LL AGREE NOW, THE
POLICY WITHOUT THE VIOLENCE
SHOULD BE THE FUTURE OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I THINK THEY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL ON THAT.
>> JULIETTE, ELLIOT, SCOTT,
DAVID, WE GOT MORE THAN OUR
MONEY'S WORTH.
YOU HAVE TO COME BACK.